[Música]
joe biden y vladimir putin se reunirán a
discutir la crisis con ucrania esto
ocurre el mismo día en el que
manifestantes salieron a las calles de
washington para pedirle al líder de la
casa blanca que tenga determinaciones
frente al kremlin
república dominicana comienza a
construir un nuevo muro en su frontera
con haití los 160 kilómetros de valla
esperan detener a los migrantes que
cruzan del vecino país esta fue una
promesa que hizo el presidente
dominicano luis abinader el año pasado
el incendio forestal en argentina ya ha
consumido el 10 por ciento de la
superficie de la provincia de corrientes
mientras que paraguay los ganaderos y
los agricultores estiman pérdidas
millonarias por la sequía que no da
tregua
[Música]
bienvenidos a las noticias de américa
esto es france24 y mi nombre es maría
clara calle y comenzamos hablando de que
el presidente de eeuu joe biden y su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin se reunirán
para discutir sobre la crisis en ucrania
así lo confirmó el elíseo luego de que
este domingo el mandatario francés
emmanuel marco conversará
telefónicamente con bailén y en dos
ocasiones con putin mientras en europa
del este- intentan la vía diplomática en
washington cientos de personas se
reunieron para mostrar su solidaridad
con ucrania ellos le piden a bailén que
ponga límites que putin no esté
dispuesto a cruzar la marcha terminó en
frente de la casa blanca
el presidente yo vaivén dice que está
listo para involucrar al presidente ruso
vladimir putin esperamos sinceramente
que el presidente bailen dibujen líneas
rojas que el presidente putin no cruzara
es obvio en este punto que la diplomacia
es la única solución a la situación que
se está desarrollando en torno a ucrania
y solo esperemos que esta conversación
sea una de las muchas conversaciones que
la administración de los eeuu sostendrá
con rusia porque cualquier mala paz es
mucho mejor que una buena guerra y
república dominicana- el domingo el
presidente luís abinader anunció el
inicio de la construcción de una verja
en la frontera noreste con haití una
medida que justificó por motivos de
seguridad esto se da cuando activistas
están denunciando las políticas
migratorias de la administración
dominicana contra los haitianos el
informe es de luís muñoz
un nuevo muro contra la migración
república dominicana e inició este
domingo la construcción de una verja
fronteriza
inteligente
el presidente luís abinader celebró
desde abajo en la medida sin embargo la
república dominicana no puede hacerse
cargo de la crisis política económica de
ese país ni resolver tampoco el resto de
sus problemas
apostando por la vía legal como la única
forma posible de entrar en nuestro
territorio una frontera
es una frontera mucho más segura
la baya tendrá 160 km dispositivos
tecnológicos y estará lista entre 7 y 9
meses
ante esta noticia los haitianos se
apuran para cruzar el paso fronterizo
este proyecto había sido anunciado hace
alrededor de un año por el presidente
quien ha hecho política de gobierno el
control fronterizo
precisamente el 7 de julio tras el
asesinato del presidente de haití job en
el mois llegó a cerrar completamente la
frontera
sin embargo esta gestión migratoria está
siendo rechazada por organizaciones
internacionales a finales de 2021 600
activistas de república dominicana en
más de 20 países firmaron un documento
llamado las vidas haitianas importan en
el texto se condena la deportación de
mujeres embarazadas capturadas junto a
hospitales además de la suspensión del
programa de visados para universitarios
haitianos todo esto cuando en 2021
fueron deportados más de 31 mil
haitianos
regresa la calma a canadá tras 24 días
de movilizaciones la policía desalojó de
los transportistas que protestaban en
ottawa en contra de la vacunación de
kobe 19 además detuvieron a cerca de 200
manifestantes y remolcaron más de 75
camiones sin embargo los transportistas
del llamado convoy de la libertad
prometen volver pronto en entrevista con
france 24 david ramírez uno de los
manifestantes nos explicó que las
movilizaciones continúan en algunas
provincias canadienses y en ottawa se
calmó a raíz de la intervención ayer de
la policía
provincial una intervención más o menos
violenta hacia los protestantes así que
apagaron un poco el foco de protesta y
no está agua las protestas siguen en el
oeste hay protestas ahorita en calgary
de protesta en betis columbia hubieron
protestas este fin de semana en la
ciudad de québec en la provincia de
quebec
y según lo que me han informado creo que
la gente que protesto los organizadores
y todo que están en notado están
reagrupando para hacer seguir
protestando en otros lugares porque lo
que yo quieren hacer es que tomen los
mandatos de todos para todo el mundo que
la gente pueda poder regresar a sus
trabajos sin necesidad
a ser obligado a vacunarse y esas cosas
una de las playas de chile se cubrió con
miles de sardinas y anchoas muertas este
hecho ocurrió en la región del bío bío
en el centro del país austral
concretamente frente a la costa de la
península de coliumo los funcionarios
ambientales están estudiando la calidad
del agua para determinar si esta
mortandad se debe a los bajos niveles de
oxígeno en las aguas más profundas o si
existe otra causa diferente esta no es
una zona apta para el baño
y no hay accesibilidad tampoco para que
bajar maquinarias por lo tanto como lo
hacemos cuando tenemos que ir a hacer
limpieza de algas en nuestro borde
costero pero acá no podemos por lo tanto
lo vamos a hacer con trabajadores las
altas temperaturas y la falta de
precipitaciones agravan los incendios en
el noroeste de argentina una situación
que también afecta a parte de paraguay
los agricultores y ganaderos estiman que
esta situación climática impactará
negativamente a la economía de la nación
para los meteorólogos este calor extremo
y sus repercusiones
de la crisis climática marinas ardilla
tiene la información
el fuego no da tregua en el noroeste de
argentina casi un 10% de la superficie
de la provincia de corrientes quedó
arrasada por las llamas que amenazan la
fauna y flora del parque natural de
iberá el mayor humedal del país
la intensidad del fuego que se fue
repartiendo lo mismo que acaba ha pasado
en otros lugares
hoy el 9% de la provincia está en la
misma situación
y realmente una provincia verde llena de
agua hoy la estamos defendiendo de la
intensa sequía mientras los bomberos
llevan semanas luchando para frenar los
incendios que se están agravando por las
sequías consecuencias según los expertos
de la crisis climática lo que supone un
duro golpe para la economía de esta
región rural argentina que este tipo de
eventos sequías más prolongadas y más
frecuentes es lo que estaría trayendo
consigo lo que está trayendo consigo
este cambio una situación similar sufre
el vecino paraguay debido a la escasez
de lluvia las altas temperaturas y las
fuertes sequías en el país han hecho
sonar las alarmas entre los ganaderos y
agricultores paraguayos que anticipan
millonarias pérdidas y es que paraguay
es el cuarto exportador mundial de soja
si no no tenemos lluvia en la abundancia
o por lo menos en en promedios anuales
no en nuestros pastos no no no
no crecen entonces por ende el animal
tiene poco alimento por ende la
producción hay baja de terneros los los
novillo no engordan lo suficiente y así
sucesivamente verdad los meteorólogos
advierten que la ola de calor extremo
continuará la próxima semana y sólo se
prevén precipitaciones ocasionales los
artistas hicieron una protesta simbólica
para reclamar que uno de los tesoros
prehispánicos vuelva a méxico y no esté
más en el museo de viena
el publicista josu arangüena y el
documentalista sebastián arrechedera
infiltraron 50 audioguías para pedir que
el penacho de moctezuma sea devuelto a
sus orígenes y denuncian un saque
europeo
previamente arrechedera uno de los
autores del hackeo nos explicó como
infiltraron estas audioguías y que dice
el audio
el audio lo que dice son 8 minutos de
hecho conoce tus gone ahora que es un
activista mexicano que ha luchado
durante 40 años por que vuelva la corona
como le gusta llamarla el hinojo penacho
así que lo que hicimos fue infiltrar su
voz para que lo escucharan mucha gente
dentro del museo y también
parlamentarios del parlamento austríaco
terminamos en bolivia porque este país
andino volvió a vivir sus fiestas
después de posponer las dos años a causa
de la pandemia del cob y 19 se trata del
carnaval de oruro declarado patrimonio
de la humanidad alcaldía de la paz
organizó una exhibición de danzas
denominada danza en movimiento carnaval
sin alcohol en la que participaron cerca
de 400 bailarines además hubo más de
2.000 asistentes que escucharon ritmos
de las diferentes regiones bolivianas
como la morenada los caporales o
moseñada el objetivo es que la
celebración sea algo más familiar y sin
alcohol
[Música]
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
sobre el continente americano los
invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24 y con france24 punto com
[Música]